les réfugiés seulement continuent
d'affluer en bavière un émissaire
soviétique de haut rang condamne à
berlin ce qu'il appelle une opération de
débauchage le gouvernement réajuste son
plan pour l'emploi nouveaux allègements
de charges pour les entreprises
meilleure formation pour les chômeurs
l'avenir de la corse les recommandations
raisonnable du rapport prada établi
après la grève du printemps dernier
danièle gilbert toujours en prison après
une longue confrontation prévue qui ne
l'a pas libéré
madame monsieur bonsoir combien sont-ils
ce soir entassés dans les camps
organisés au cordeau par la croix rouge
allemande la police des frontières
bavaroise n'est pas parvenu aujourd'hui
à compter précisément le nombre de
réfugiés est allemands qui ont afflué
toute la journée de hongrie plus de dix
mille en tout cas largement plus de
10000 presque tous de la même génération
des jeunes déjà formés au travail des
brouillards le levain d'une société
qu'il fuit et qui va enrichir à l'ouest
une économie en pleine croissance
les patrons allemands ne s'y trompe pas
qui sont déjà dans les camps pour
sélectionner et embaucher sur place en
bavière
philippe rochot alliés droite en 24
heures le camp de vince open s'est
transformé en réservoir de main d'oeuvre
cette femme au blouson de cuir et celle
du personnel dans une clinique
elle cherche des infirmières et demande
à ses jeunes réfugiés
si elles sont qualifiées elle a fait 300
kilomètres de toul mais pour coller
cette annonce seize états d'asie ce mot
cliché vous pensé trouver des
infirmières il y en a pas beaucoup
j'en ai rencontré deux seulement mais
elles veulent rester ici avec leurs amis
malgré le chômage
on trouve plus de puéricultrice et avec
des employés d'allemagne de l'est
on peut les payer moins cher c'est plus
facile
les panneaux d'affichage du camp déborde
déjà des annonces d'entreprises qui
demandent des menuisiers des tourneurs
des chauffeurs de camion alors que
l'allemagne fédérale compte deux
millions de chômeurs c'est allé très
vite pour moi je suis surprise à bagdad
le chômage ici vous avez trouvé aussi
facilement pourquoi un challenge que je
suis serveuse et peut-être qu'ici il n'y
a pas beaucoup de volontaires pour faire
ce travail
ici c'est une entreprise du centre de
l'allemagne fédérale qui cherchent du
personnel et espère en trouver parmi les
réfugiés débarqués hier on a trop peu
d'ingénieurs et de main d'oeuvre
qualifiée en électronique
c'est pour ça qu'on est là pour vous ça
revient moins cher aussi d'employer des
allemands de l'est
non non non non non pas du tout on les
paye la même chose que les autres et on
fournit même l'appartement
ici on demande un maçon moi je suis
soudeur et monteur de chaînes de
machines pas maçon je suis déjà en
contact avec des firmes
quand j'ai parlé avec ses mains enfin
reste les deux mines enfants des
réfugiés qui devront obligatoirement
être intégrés dans les écoles des cités
où s'installeront les familles
la vague de réfugiés semble se tarir ce
soir mais d'autres allemands de l'est
serait en route vers la hongrie à
travers la tchécoslovaquie et la
roumanie l'allemagne fédérale
annoncé tout à l'heure l'octroi d'un
crédit d'impôt 7 milliards de francs en
faveur de la hongrie sans rapport dit
ans avec la sphère des réfugiés aucun
rapport non plus officiellement du moins
entre la sphère et l'arrivée à berlin
tout à l'heure de igor likhatchev
membres très conservateur du bureau
politique du parti communiste soviétique
une visite qui intervient juste après
une déclaration de l'agent stase
réaffirmant le soutien indéfectible de
moscou à l'allemagne de l'est
sans accuser pourtant la hongrie georges
bortoli monsieur les gars de shaft chef
de file des conservateurs du kremlin
trouve en allemagne de l'est des
interlocuteurs selon son goût il tombe
des dirigeants communistes qui ne parle
ni de perry strauss kahn ni de glace
nost il trouva régime du rpt qui
interdit la liberté d'expression ce qui
n'empêche pas ses citoyens de
revendiquer le droit à l'immigration
comme ceux ci qui le 4 septembre dernier
a les pieds étaient dispersés par la
stasi la police politique
on ne sait pas sur quoi cette visite
monsieur légal chauffe pour avoir
monsieur necker celui qui a représenté
l'allemagne de l'est si longtemps est
partout de berlin moscou y de moscou à
paris serait très malade mais monsieur
necker reste le visage d'une allemagne
de l'est
crispés sur son passé ne mèneraient ce
qui a tout de même reçu un certain
réconfort et un certain appui de la part
de moscou puisque l'agent stas vous le
disiez la nuit dernière puis monsieur
légal choc tout à l'heure à berlin ont
condamné ce que monsieur l'igad chauffe
appelle le débauchage des citoyens de la
république démocratique allemande par
certains milieux de la république
fédérale allemande donc voilà un
avertissement en direction de bonnes sur
le thème
surtout n'allez pas trop loin mais
seulement en direction de gaulle oui et
or délaissant de la hongrie en revanche
alors on y en a un regret les propos de
moscou le ton de moscou reste tout à
fait courtois contrairement à ce qui se
passe entre la hongrie et la république
démocratique allemande alors là on n'ose
plus parler de pays frères selon la
vieille phraséologie car le gouvernement
reste allemand en est accusé par note
officielle la hongrie d'avoir violé le
droit international et à communiquer
très dur qui est tombé donc en fin de
journée à prague
la majorité des allemands de l'est qui
s'était réfugié à l'ambassade ouest
allemandes ont quitté les lieux sur la
promesse qu'il ne serait pas poursuivi
et qu'il pourrait tenter d'émigrer
légalement la grande moitié aveugle de
l'europe commencent à voir le jour
demain matin en conseil des ministres
michel rocard présentera le nouveau plan
emploi de son gouvernement
les grands axes restent ceux de l'an
dernier moins de charges pour les
entreprises plus de formation pour les
chômeurs
maryse mano en connaît déjà l'essentiel
la fin des tuques c'est ce qui marquera
le second plan rocard pour l'emploi en
perte de vitesse ils vont disparaître au
profit de véritables contrats de travail
rémunérées sur la base du smic
ce changement de statut devrait offrir
aux jeunes les mêmes droits sociaux
qu'aux salariés et doublure et leur
salaire environ 2500 francs pour un mi
temps donc je crois que maintenant les
conditions sont au contraire réunis pour
qu'ils attirent à nouveau des jeunes
outre mesure qui peut être prise
nécessite que ce soit pour l'emploi
stable dans l'entreprise sinon eh bien
nous allons recommencer
le cercle infernal de l'emploi précaire
du chômage etc
la lutte contre l'exclusion c'est le
volet social du plan rocard le volet
économique lui fait appel aux mêmes
recettes que l'on dernier allègement des
charges patronales pour encourager les
entreprises à embaucher les salariés peu
qualifiés 1% de moins pour les charges
d'allocations familiales baisse des
cotisations accidents du travail deux
points de moins pour l'impôt sur les
bénéfices réinvestis
mais aussi encouragement financier à la
création de tout nouvel emploi il n'y a
pas
véritablement d'allègement des charges
il ya transfert de charge par le
déplafonnement des allocations
familiales et des actions du travail de
certains secteurs vers d'autres
évidemment les secteurs qui en
bénéficieront serons très heureux ceux
qui verront une augmentation le sont
moins enfin le plan rocard subvention à
la clé veut encourager la réduction du
temps de travail en utilisant au mieux
les machines mais aussi en limitant le
recours excessif aux heures
supplémentaires
autant de freins à l'embauché de
nouveaux salariés mais rappelons les
chiffres pour situer l'échelle du
problème deux millions et demi de
chômeurs en france dont quelques 800
mille dits de longue durée plus d'un an
sans emploi pourtant l'économie tourne
deux cent cinquante mille emplois ont
été créés l'an dernier paradoxe beaucoup
d'entreprises ne trouve pas la main
d'oeuvre qu'elle cherche
et elle abuse des heures supplémentaires
comme cette entreprise d'auxerre le fief
du ministre en charge en pierre soisson
reportage
véronique auger jeanne gérard plantons
le décor juin côté scène les enfants
abandonnent l'école pour deux mois délai
unique est idéal pour refaire la cantine
tout bon chef d'établissement qui se
respecte souhaite du sur-mesure juin
côté coulisses louis guyot leader en
france dans la fabrication de ce genre
de cuisine
une seule alternative s'impose à lui ou
bien ils refusent certaines commandes
des lycées et collèges qui se bousculent
en été solution exclue ou bien c'est 100
salariés dépassent leur quota d'heures
supplémentaires par cette lettre il
demande une dérogation
il souhaite quatre heures de plus par
personne et par semaine l'inspection du
travail décide de ne lui en accorder que
la moitié
comme beaucoup de patrons ils décident
de passer outre aujourd'hui il s'avère
que nous avons une très grande
difficulté de trouver du personnel
qualifié que d'autre part tourné et
trouver du personnel disponible
surtout en période de vacances parce que
notre cher la plus importante se situe
sur les mois de juin juillet août
puisque nous fournissons aux du matériel
de grande cuisine pour tous qui est
collèges lycées écoles et s'avère
qu'elles s'avèrent en cette période est
très difficile de trouver des personnes
disponibles une situation de manque qui
ici comme ailleurs arrange les salariés
déjà en place
vous pensez qu'en fait on trouve
personne à votre nom de même si on était
quelqu'un de fatma il faudrait le
remplacer ça c'est évident mais
étant donné qu'il n'a pas l'habitude de
travail que j'effectue tout au long de
l'année
il est préférable à mon sens comme
prennent à moi vous entreprises hors la
loi heureuse où le pdj peut même faire
des heures supplémentaires de chez lui
le président mitterrand a inauguré ce
matin les premières rencontres annuelles
de la formation professionnelle à la
villette à paris
dans son discours il a défini ce qu'il a
appelé le carré magique de l'éducation
au 21e siècle c'est à dire 80 % de
bacheliers par classe d'âge réforme des
programmes formation continue et surtout
égalité d'accès aux diplômes tout jeune
doit atteindre à l'issue de sa scolarité
un niveau de formation reconnu on le
certificat d'aptitude professionnelle
brevet d'études professionnelles
on peut imaginer ce que l'on voudra un
diplôme reconnu puisque société
fonctionne sur ces données font ses
parents
et puis après tout c'est un bon critère
mais c'est à nous tous qui la porte de
briser cette injuste enchaînement qui
conduit encore chaque année cent mille
jeunes est la sortie de l'école sans
aucun diplôme
on imagine ce qu'il devienne il sait
bien
quant à la réforme des programmes le
ministère de l'éducation nationale vient
d'envoyer 1 millions de questionnaires
dans tout le pays et aux enseignants aux
parents pour avoir leur avis
ramassage des copies en décembre une
succession très convoité celle de
jean-claude good à la présidence du
groupe udf de l'assemblée nationale
trois candidats se sont déjà déclarés
françois léotard philippe mestre et
charles millon voilà qui ne va pas
cicatrisé les divisions au sein de l'udf
nom de l'élu le 25 septembre prochain à
vichy en pologne le gouvernement d'état
des houches mazodier ce qui a été
massivement approuvé par le parlement le
premier ministre lee a été pris d'un
malaise pendant son discours
non sans humour il a comparé son état de
fatigue à celui de l'économie polonaise
jacques merlino
difficile est impressionnant d'être le
premier chef de gouvernement non
communiste dans un pays de l'est
tadeusz mazowiecki en tout cas semble
déjà bien fatigué quand je sèche
respiration difficile il cas là au bout
de 45 minutes de son discours
d'investiture et fut alors contraints de
se tourner vers le président du
parlement
monsieur cosaques et beach pour lui
demander de suspendre la séance et ce
n'est que trente minutes plus tard qu'il
revint après que les médecins lui aient
fait un rapide examen cardiaque
le général josé ski qui assistait à la
séance dans la tribune présidentielle
reste a comme à l'accoutumée un passif
avec humour
tadeusz mazowiecki estima que sa santé
ressembler à celle de l'économie
polonaise
je m'en suis sorti déclara-t-il j'espère
que l'économie de mon pays s'en sortira
aussi un souhait ratifié par le
parlement le gouvernement de monsieur
m'a sauvé ce qui fut investi à une très
large majorité 402 voix 104-115 veut pas
100 jours 100 jours déjà que la
répression du régime chinois s'est
abattue sur la place tiananmen
une cérémonie doit avoir lieu ce soir au
parvis des droits de l'homme à paris
d'après le quotidien de pékin ce matin
la sécurité de la capitale chinoise
reste toujours sous la menace des
conspirateurs mais quel visage font
aujourd'hui les étudiants de pékin
quelle ambiance dans les universités
philippe menut et dominique torrès
reviennent de pékin
c'est ici que résonnaient les discours
enflammés des leaders étudiants
ces deux là qu'a surgi le printemps de
pékin sur ces panneaux s'afficher les
principaux mots d'ordre et les fragments
d'espoir aujourd'hui université de
beidaihe puni à rentrer et repousser les
élèves sont soumis à des contrôles
politique
un tiers des étudiants sont astreints à
une période militaire d'un an
l'université de xinhua
les cours ont recommencé l'excès
brimades
ces contrôles ici aussi le silence
un seul étudiant acceptera de parler de
parler de cet étrange rentrée certains
étudiants parlent de tout ça ils ne sont
pas d'accord avec le gouvernement mais
ils doivent se réinscrire en fac tous
les ans et s'ils ne manifestent pas leur
adhésion au gouvernement alors ne
pourront pas s'inscrire
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit cours politique
oui ils ont au moins trois cours
d'éducation politique par semaine matin
midi ou soir
aujourd'hui l'autocritique est de mise
aussi bien pour les professeurs que pour
les étudiants qui se réfugient dans des
occupations sans risque
il ya trois mois tous ces étudiants
réclamer bruyamment dans la rue plus de
démocratie et plus de libertés
aujourd'hui ils se taisent chacun
gardant pour lui ces espoirs blessés
d'autres reportage tourné
clandestinement en chine par nos équipes
seront demain soir à 22h15 au programme
de résistance un numéro entièrement
consacré au grand bond en arrière de la
chine demain soir dont 22h15 afrique du
sud
une première le gouvernement
sud-africain autorise la grande marche
anti apartheid prévue demain dans la
ville du cap
c'est bien la première fois que le
gouvernement autorise une marche de
protestation
et puis cet attentat tout à l'heure en
plein madrid un procureur de la plus
haute instance juridique espagnol a été
mitraillé à bout portant dans un parking
un attentat qui d'après les autorités
portent la marque de letea quel avenir
pour la corse en plus de 500 pages le
rapport prada du nom du haut
fonctionnaire chargé de comprendre les
ressorts de la grève du printemps
dernier ce rapport prada donc suggère
tout un ensemble de mesures qui
paraissent tout à fait raisonnable en
tout cas aux continentaux et que résume
françoise joly voici cinq cents pages et
quelques clés pour décrypter le malaise
corse
en première ligne les prix effectivement
remplir son chariot en corse coûte plus
cher que sur le continent
mais surprise les cas relevés n'est que
de 5% sur le banc des accusés les
transports intérieurs déficient et des
distributeurs en situation de quasi
monopole avec des exemples cités connu
le carburant ou le ciment deuxième volet
du rapport prada la continuité
territoriale et la nouvelle surprise
la subvention de 753 millions de francs
attribué cette année à la corse est
plutôt bien employé mais un point noir
des coûts de gestion des mesures et l'an
prochain
150 millions de francs devront être
économisés mais la table ronde qui a
suscité le plus de polémique et celle
portant sur la fiscalité la corse
bénéficie d'importants avantages fiscaux
qui selon les auteurs du rapport profite
aux consommateurs aux dépens des
entreprises
un argument contesté par certains élus
corses même s'il accueille plutôt
favorablement ce rapport
il ya la partie fiscale on a un peu
l'impression que ces propositions faites
par des néo par des technocrates ont
pour objet de renier les quelques
avantages dont bénéficie la corse pour
les redéployer
certes dans le sens de l'investissement
productif mais sans qu'un effort de
solidarité nationale volontariste soit
fait en faveur de l'accord enfin
concernant le malaise dans la fonction
publique michel prada recommande entre
autres des négociations sur le
déroulement des carrières
quant au développement économique de
l'île le rapport donne la priorité aux
activités touristiques et dans le cas
d'une action concertée pour éviter le
courroux des nationalistes c'est à la
fin du mois prochain qu'un comité
interministériel décidera du sort du
rapport prada manifestations
inhabituelles tout à l'heure à paris
celle de quelque 15 mille agents des
finances notamment ceux des impôts
parmi eux dans la pluie jean-pierre
m'étirer noël alexandre leurs grillades
ministre at-il dure depuis quatre mois
dans la rue sont chaque fois plus
nombreux
quinze mille aujourd'hui mais attention
pour le dernier tiers
les chèques seront encaissés à leur
seule conséquence la tva ne rentre plus
dans les caisses de l'état et cela se
chiffrent par milliards une prime de
2200 francs pour l'année
c'est ce qu'ils ont déjà obtenus et les
syndicats réclame 700 francs par mois et
rappelle le meilleur traitement fait aux
collègues d'en face chaque fois que le
dossier éducation nationale a bougé
l'agent des impôts a essayé de coller à
l'évolution éducation nationale
l'inspecteur des impôts lorgne sur le
salaire du professeur certifié le
contrôleur des impôts lorgnait sur le
salaire de l'instituteur c'est
historique
en échange va rien un signe l'état-major
de la cgt s'étaient déplacés mais pour
l'instant la grève n'a pas réussi à
s'étendre au delà de la direction des
emplois
la production des 205 bloqué à mulhouse
le conflit chez peugeot et d'autres
informations plus brèves avec anne pour
signer
production paralysé à peugeot mulhouse
la dernière chaîne encore en
fonctionnement bloqué et occupé depuis
ce matin la cfdt réclame aujourd'hui 500
francs d'augmentation du salaire mensuel
de base
en revanche dans l' usine de sochaux
situation plus calme la production était
normal ce matin
yves rocher inculpé démissionne de ses
mandats d'élus locaux ici en mars
dernier l'industriel avait fait
descendre dans la rue dix mille
habitants du morbihan pour le soutenir
contre la bnp
la banque qui lui aurait revendu luz il
petit bateau sans lui dire qu'elle était
en difficultés
suite à cette manifestation la banque
avait forcé plainte pour chantage
extorsions de fonds
michel villemin le frère de jean marie
villemin aurait subi filière atteste
graphologique lors de son interrogatoire
à la gendarmerie de bruyère réaction
aujourd'hui de monique villain
grand-mère de grégory
je pense que ceux qui te donne une
grande valeur on mange de confiance nous
avons confiance en lui et il faut
concerter
et si on se parlait titre d'un
documentaire sur les relations
police-population présenté aujourd'hui
par le ministre de l'intérieur pierre
joxe
ce film retrace une expérience de
dialogue entre police et population les
services de police urbaine le verrons
prochainement forts organisés à leur
tour de telles expériences
deux façons de fêter aujourd'hui le 16e
anniversaire du coup d'état militaire au
chili en septembre 60 fraises
officiellement discours et larmes devant
augusto pinochet le général averti que
même après son retrait du pouvoir en
mars prochain
il ne permettra pas un retour au pouvoir
d'une politique démagogique et
officieusement recueillement et
arrestations par dizaines pour les
manifestants venus rendre hommage aux
victimes du coup d'état
t'as plus qu à la bourse de paris
l'indicateur de tendance en légère
hausse +0 08 %
le dollar perd 0 65% à 6 francs 76 65
va t on pas revenir pour la première
fois en france à juger un français pour
crimes contre l'humanité et à travers
lui la politique antijuive du régime de
vichy
c'est en tout cas l'objectif de l'avocat
serge klarsfeld qui a déposé une plainte
contre rené bousquet l'ancien secrétaire
général de la police de vichy
dans son dossier de nouveaux éléments
hervé brusini les aux dérogations
prévues sont supprimés par ces quelques
mots au moins 194 enfants jusqu'à leur
épargner était envoyé en déportation
ce télégramme est signée rené bousquet
nous sommes le 18 août 42
cet homme est secrétaire général à la
police sous le régime de vichy l'ordre
écrit qu'il vient ainsi de donner c'est
la première pièce du dossier déposé
contre lui
autre élément cette décision du juge et
y elle concerne jean leguay décédé
depuis quelques semaines le guay était
pendant la guerre le subordonné de rené
bousquet arrestation extermination de
populations entières dans son ordonnance
le juge et y affirme la participation de
le guet à des crimes contre l'humanité
alors si l'accusation est établie contre
le subordonné
comment son chef rené bousquet
pourrait-il échapper à la justice c'est
le raisonnement que font les deux
avocats charles lipman et serge par
semaine
ce que nous recherchons c'est vraiment
la condamnation de régime de vichy dans
ce qu'il a de plus odieux c'est à dire
la livraison de milliers de familles et
de milliers d'enfants à aux nazis qui
n'avait pas dissimulé leurs menaces à
l'égard de 2d des juifs
bousquet est le dernier représentant de
cette france qui envoya 90 mille juifs
dans les camps de la mort pauvre daniel
gilbert et l'a regagné sa cellule à la
prison de nice et elle ne peut même plus
porter sa bague miraculeuse qui a été
déposée au greffe
manifestement éprouvé par
en attaque car ces rations danièle
gilbert a été entendu pendant plus de
trois heures est confronté un autre
inculpé par le juge à grasse dominique
verdeilhan et bernard connor le visage
défait le regard absent
après cinq jours de détention à la
prison des femmes à nice danièle gilbert
et apparaît amaigri métamorphoser à
l'arrière du fourgon de la gendarmerie
se dissimule derrière des lunettes
noires marquent tripier le cerveau de la
faire le créateur de la bague dorée
durant plus de trois heures le juge jean
pierre murciano va les confronter afin
d'établir le degré d'implication de l'ex
animatrice quand le fonctionnement de la
société produisant la bague miraculeux
vous vous imaginez bien que c'est une
publicité qui a eu un impact assez
important
et on ne peut pas ne pas être au courant
aussi en à parité on ne peut pas un jour
où l'autre ne pas avoir eu connaissance
mais cette publication dont vous vous
doutez bien que si
si elle n'avait pas été d'accord il faut
savoir pour les avocats de daniel
gilbert la confrontation a démontré que
les déclarations des deux inculpés
étaient concordants ils ont demandé la
mise en liberté de leur client
chaque seconde chaque minute et chaque
heure qui passe est un véritable drame
humain pour ma cliente est que j'espère
que monsieur le juge donnera conscience
pour qu'une décision soit rapidement
prises en sa faveur
le juge a cinq jours pour se prononcer à
sa sortie du palais de justice daniel
gilbert est restée muette devant micros
et caméras
l'ex-animatrice s'apprête à passer sa
septième nuit en prison
il faut écouter les anciens et mettre à
profit leur sagesse ce n'est pas souvent
le cas chez nous même en politique
mais le maire de saint-coulitz dans le
finistère fait exception et il convient
de le saluer dans sa commune de 354
habitants
kofi yamgnane a mis en place un conseil
des sages
vous l'aurez compris en écoutant son nom
il n'est pas vraiment bretons il vient
du togo de cette afrique où les anciens
compte encore vincent gerard et noël
alexandre prendre deux bretons mairie de
saint-coulitz salle du conseil municipal
le maire met la main à la pâte car c'est
un jour très important c'est le jour de
la réunion du conseil des sages des
anciens sollicités chaque mois pour
donner leur avis au maire il s'appelle
marie joséphine thérèse ou henry ils
sont neuf âgées de 60 à 80 il ya des
choses qui ne sont pas écrits même dans
une situation écrit et pour moi les
anciens de ce village sont la mémoire
vivante du village
depuis les dernières élections
saint-coulitz solidement ancré dans ses
traditions bretonnes c'était fort bien
habitué à son nouveau maire mais le
conseil des sages c'était vraiment
inattendu
c'est la première fois que j'entends
parfaite et je trouve que c'est très bon
je pensais que c'était rien je crois que
c'était pour le café comment ça pour le
cap et c'est à dire via une fois par
mois le café des anciens ici c'est du
sérieux
les neuf sages choisis par les 80
membres du club 3e âge ont des choses à
dire
ils sont heureux de pouvoir enfin les
dire oui mais arrivé à ces empannages
on n'avait plus droit à la parole nous
allons vous voulez lancer quelque chose
vous avez des idées on nous écoute pas
et vous pensez que vous pouvez apporter
quelque chose
oui répondent oui je pense que je peux
encore apporter quelque chose à la
société actuellement le voile à la
mairie ils donneront leur avis sur tout
sur le réaménagement de la mairie sur
une route à mettre en sens unique sur le
prix des terrains et ça avec
enthousiasme une telle maison vous
laissez pas la raffinerie
les palabres sont animées et le maire
notre atout avec application mais pas
question pourtant de faire du conseil
des sages un organe de décision
allez y et le conseil municipal peut
parfaitement décidé le contraire de ce
qu'a dit le conseil des sages mais au
moins j'ai logé et j'aurais eu le mérite
de les avoir consultés de savoir que
d'autres peuvent penser ce n'est pas
parce qu'on a trempé un million de
points et un bâton dans un marigot
qu'ils deviennent audibles
non je ne serai jamais complètement je
ne serai jamais un blanc je suis un noir
jeunes africains je le reste et pour ne
pas faire des blagues
il faut que je me rapproche que j'écoute
les anciens saint-coulitz continue à
vivre tranquillement sa petite
révolution et après le conseil les neuf
sages rentreront chez eux à l'heure loin
de saint-coulitz les lions vont boire
demain encore pour vous dire que silvio
berlusconi reste à la 5 et participe à
l'augmentation de capital demandée par
robert hersant
pas de bouleversement donc dans le petit
monde des médias qui guettait la
décision d'entrepreneurs italiens qui
est aussi actionnaire de tf1 et puis au
carnet rose un deuxième enfant bientôt
pour la duchesse d'york et pour le duc
le bilan de la reine est ravie paraît-il
quel temps demain que sophie davant
l'impact de gros changements de
maintenir des averses au nord de la
loire un temps couvert sur le sud ouest
et du beau temps sur le sudes des
températures stationnaires voilà et des
détails tout de suite après la pub
un mot encore est enfin non plusieurs
plusieurs parce que j'ai les rapports du
tiercé et du nouveau quinté plus alors
le tiercé à l'arrivée le 8 le 4 le 1 5
francs rapporte dans l'ordre 810 francs
dans un ordre différent 160 de francs le
quinté+ lui se joue
vous le savez sur 10 francs alors
l'ordre exa d'arrivée 160 3558 francs un
ordre différent 2578 francs
le bonus 4 vous savez sûrement ce que ça
veut dire 296 freins et non pas 2 176
comme la fiche votre écran le bonus 3 24
francs le tout dans pour 10 francs
voilà à 23h30 henri sannier vous donnera
les dernières nouvelles de la soirée
demain télématin bien sûr à partir de
6h30 et à 7h45 invité des 4 vérités gens
ont fait le man qui est chômeur à 55 ans
très bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain
vapeur et tout de suite sophie davant